[Music]
welcome back to another amazing episode
of the careful boys
we are extremely careful we're so
careful that today what we are going to
talk about is how
if you could choose
you could choose if you could choose how
would you like to die strangling anthony
lead to death
i'm going to die
so you're he's dying and you're dying no
then you go
trying to kill me it's like luke
skywalker dying like he took all my life
force to just
kill this son of a [ __ ]
you know like that wrong this book gets
a heart attack while choking anthony and
he just died
he died from exhaustion you're gonna die
from bloodlust because you have such a
hard boner you're good that's good it's
all the blood brush that you're gonna
[ __ ] seize up and die
that's a good idea
i did have a dream that i was in the
plane
and then for some reason it went like
this uh-huh and then it was just
straight down like this
and then i [ __ ] slammed into the
earth and i died and i was like that's
really scary but also seems there's like
a cool place like that
straight down like that too thinking on
your feet though
run your ass to the back of the plane
and then that's what bane did that's
what being did that was abandoned yeah
you double jump off the back of the
plane the fire rises
death by plane crash is pretty epic but
like would you be like the pilot or
you're just another passenger i was just
a passenger the movie you watched 35 e
or some [ __ ]
while watching flight going down while
watching
going down watching final destination
that's good too
do you want an exciting death or a calm
nice peaceful one
if i had it the way i wanted to i'll
[ __ ] die in my sleep and never know
but for the sake of this video i think
it needs to be glorious i don't mind i i
don't want a painful death but if it is
i hope it's an extreme amount in a split
second yes
like if i got incinerated or something
so like if you if you like got like
kicked into a [ __ ] volcano yeah
that'd be better than [ __ ] sucked up
in an airplane turbine first though you
know it's pretty good but it sounds
funny
you die right away you get kicked into
the volcano you felt like a huge amount
of pain and then you died right away i
feel like the adrenaline is gonna
outweigh whatever [ __ ] little pain it
is dude how about this huh [ __ ] put
me on a chain to lower me into the
vulcan
and it was like why has he killed
himself it's so weird what a weird video
give it a thumbs up
[Laughter]
you think it'd be better if they lowered
you in the volcano like right away or if
you spent 15 minutes in a costco
refrigerator first oh
wait wait what because you're getting
thawed out no way i wouldn't be
either way i wouldn't be as cool as the
movie never been there it's [ __ ] cold
in there you're getting lowered by the
change and then you're like you're
supposed to be epic and cool and you're
like oh [ __ ] hot
you're probably already hot by the like
when you're over here like your feet are
already on fire
you start to catch fire
the worst idea ever
hey dude you're talking about epic
though or you're wrestling with somebody
right on top of a [ __ ] vat of ooze or
or some sort of like yeah green goo
and then you fall over the balcony
you're talking about the balcony
two people fighting over balcony
everyone here wants a 90s action movie
death kinda yeah it's not bad a 90's
villain action movie well this is an
avillion remember robocop the way he uh
the guy's in a truck full of acid and
some [ __ ] and then rubble cop shoots the
[ __ ] in the car blows up and the guy
comes up all [ __ ] up and acidy yeah
that's how i want to go dang i'll be
different then mine's not 90s mine's
[ __ ] i fight with the samurai
and then my [ __ ] piece is sliding oh
that's good
you want to be mute you would go to the
afterlife not as a whole body though
dude like in pieces dude the sword fight
thing happens bart's alive for 10 more
minutes he goes to a subway orders a
sandwich
he just [ __ ] falls apart
traumatizing everyone in riverside some
way
he gets in his car put this he put a
drive swiss away
and he gets involved into tartar dude
epic very epic what's where's drowning
or in quicksand you think bro the
quicksand might be the worst way to go
it's like like because it's a glow right
and it plugs your nose and you're like
that sounds way more painful to be in my
lungs too like particles of sand as
opposed to being buried alive
that's way worse than drowning being
semi quicker
you know what i mean
yeah because i feel like uh but you're
resisting for at least 60 seconds yeah
but with water it's like the second you
stop resisting it's like it goes into
your system and then it's like it feels
and it's done right not done like right
away but like because water is going but
i feel like
but the water will fill your lungs so
much faster right but then quicksand
you're like just choking on [ __ ] sand
yeah and that's just kind of like no
longer breathing versus like breathing
in water so what's worse choking or
cinnamon challenge then that's the worst
thing right
cinnamon chocolate cinnamon challenge
the sandwiches i feel like
that's true i don't know it's all dusty
would you rather burn to death or drown
to death drown
that's true because your skin's not hurt
being hot sucks burning is probably
because burning i think you can also
like plot twist you drown by boiling
water
aka plot twist you're a lobster
[ __ ]
well at least i'll be tasty i'd rather
have steve murder me with a rock hard
motor
in boiling water yeah no boiling water
really water just look at that
rock
would you rather die in a regular fight
a knife fight or a gunfight or gunfight
probably gunfight bro yeah probably
that's way more bad fight is sick to say
though i fight is like like with a knife
gets near you or a fighter or a viking
hammer fight yeah but then if it goes
like this stick on the art major artery
you're like oh yeah kill my wife and he
could have that whole speech for 60
seconds yeah i know we got a spear here
you can't do that when you get like shot
you get you they hit an artery nick gets
in his car drives to a [ __ ] subway in
order
i just watched lone survivor dude and i
was like that seems like the way to go
dude how did he go hold up just all
these guys getting shot oh by the tree
is that the one by the tree survivor is
that that movie they made with real
marines or whatever no that's uh you
think i'm an active valor sucks dick
yeah that's cause they're not actually a
horrible thing the guy dies on the rock
on his knees and he gets shot by boss
and he's like wahlberg yeah yeah and
he's like looking off in the mountains i
was like that's tight that's that's the
way to go bro by insurgents
yeah bro you protect your country
brother
would you rather die with somebody you
know or at the hand of somebody you
don't know probably somebody i don't
know probably my greatest ally
no
i have a bunner
we all have boaters dude at subway
always has been you have to say always
has been too would you rather be beat to
death by a stick or with a samurai sword
sound right sir cut me up cut chopped up
yeah or i don't know stick is gonna take
a long time
what if it's a what if it's a big stick
are you talking like like the bear jew
from inglorious yeah yeah [ __ ] that guy
or this because you watched it sometimes
when you get cut you're bleeding and
then the pain comes later
so with the sword i'd rather get all
sliced up and i'm dead and then i'm like
oh too late too late to feel it and in
this one your [ __ ] bones are breaking
yeah dude that thing [ __ ] hurts man
reminds me of my mom and my dad [ __ ] oh
you're right
i don't know if you guys get like
beheaded by the samurai sword rather
that versus a [ __ ] giant bat hitting
me in the net concussioning you to death
yeah dude what about having a sword
fight in front of a plane propeller
like like indiana jones
it's you versus the plane
no no you're fighting the propeller i
mean you couldn't do it
there's a way to do it
if i win i get to kill the plane though
yeah so it's like one of you guys are
gonna get sucked up into the turbine
that's right that's sick damn all right
how about this death by a marvel
superhero which one oh
dude you can't go out by hawkeye don't
say hawkeye you're just arrows don't say
hi an arrow to in between your [ __ ]
eyes and then it blows up you don't want
to be sick as [ __ ] yeah but losing to a
[ __ ] sucks
what if i
i just got like vaporized by iron man
yeah yeah that's easy
yeah
i want to make out with rogue and then
she takes out all my powers and kills me
and then she talks like you for a
[ __ ] couple hours is there a lesbian
x-man i want her to suck my dick
jean grey maybe if we're going to go to
third grade let's go
because that's what happens with that
old storm she's sucking her dick in this
[ __ ] lightning round oh she
electrocutes you by sucking your dick
she puts a tornado on top of your penis
that's constantly whirling and that's
what the black knight was invaded too
much of a good thing
that's so stupid
we're death by wolverine that's like
asking the genie it's like hey it's like
asking did you need to suck your dick
and then they have a tornado suck your
dick until you die of course
jeans are so sneaky i know
was it magneto who did that thing oh you
sucked your blood iron
takes the iron out of your entire body
that sounds really painful you can do
that yeah you pull through your blood
man this movie was this dude the one
where mystique shows the dude her tits
and then he and then he goes to the
bathroom with her and then she puts the
metal inside of his bloodstream oh yeah
yes exactly rebecca romain dude yeah
dude oh it's also rebecca romaine yeah
the stamos chicken lettuce it's uh
the stamos this wasn't i thought it was
lawrence i thought it was no jeff's deal
it wasn't charlie's there absolutely
talking about dude yeah he's right he's
right it's the other one
you're thinking about the movie monster
i need to google it the stame is chick
dude yeah yeah and then she [ __ ] puts
the the medal in the dude in the
bathroom and he [ __ ] go
he's like oh no i saw titties
[Music]
thank you
hey how would you want to die
[Laughter]
with a stick or with a sword
[Laughter]
wow just asking somebody random how
would you want it that's like kind of a
scary serial killer movie oh dude that's
so crazy how would you like to die it's
like oh we're good he'd even knocked her
like you're like mad that the food was
late or something he was like holy [ __ ]
jesus christ
that's on my [ __ ] uber account what
the [ __ ] man you're gonna get not a very
good review of it right i hope okay
i need to change the tip now jesus oh my
god i gotta change a tip because he was
like how would you like to die you're
gonna come in the question it's a good
question that i thought we could get
outside opinions if you had to die
like a celebrity that has died which one
would you oh dude [ __ ] david
carradine easy one oh yeah i could choke
yourself a jacket off
really like that one i think i'll pick
that i don't know what other famous
celebrities have died like one of them
died paul walker some other ways oh i
was poor
crashing the car and burning and that
one was ironic as hell too yeah yeah
because he's very fast and too furious
because he loved cars oh i didn't think
of it like that nice
oh
there's a there's like uh
there's like left eye
you know what i mean from tlc also plane
crash was that a plane crash was it was
it
a plane crash did she die in a in a
burning home is that how left i died one
of them was like that i don't know it's
either leo or left out that was in a
plane crash i don't remember ali was
definitely a plane crash i thought they
were all in a plane crash with the
labamba guy the la bamba guy yes they're
all in the same plane with la bamba
ritchie valens didn't aaliyah just have
too much luggage and she was like she
was like one of those chicks who takes
forever to get ready and she had way too
much luggage and they told her they're
like you can't have like a door for
yourself going to die
like this is a crazy amount of luggage
and then she's like yo you put that
[ __ ] luggage on there i gotta get
ready i'm a leah if i don't if i don't
have these shoes i'm gonna die and he's
like the funny thing about that is
she had a lot of shoes not to be a
debbie downer but i know how i wouldn't
want to die huh
like kobe
a helicopter it's not about the
helicopter it's kid with with your kids
super [ __ ] up
there's absolutely nothing you can do in
that situation to make things better but
don't they go to heaven together that
was the dagger hopefully or you just you
know but i'm just saying like in that
situation where it's like you know you
can't even
think about your own like oh my life's
gonna it's like oh no this per and then
it's over yeah have you guys made that
dude [ __ ] fly in these shitty
conditions
yeah yeah yeah maybe i drove me about
getting shot like a gangster have you
guys seen the kobe girl
maybe if i'm like 80 that could be a
gangster way to go but if you're like 20
it's like man i had so much ahead of me
we're 80 years old in a gunfight no just
like getting shot up in a gang in a gang
drive by slowest gun
you know i mean it's like dude that was
shot by a gang violence drive by it's
kind of it's kind of hood
but not when you're like 20 because then
you have so much delay yeah
how did jimmy hendricks die he he died
yelling overdose right i think i would
like to die by overdose if i was
celebrating those is probably the best
way if i was a celebrity it like sounds
dark but like not overdosed because like
i had like a really really sad time in
life
go out on a bender yeah overdose because
i was partying like hella hard like
michael jackson
he wasn't that i don't think he died
again i don't think he was
done his sleep
prescription overdose prescription
overdose well
they wouldn't release the actual like i
i guess like the toxicology or whatever
the [ __ ] evidence um they're just
they were like they were like [ __ ]
holding that [ __ ] back
because they're like conspiracy or
whatever um you think he's alive is he
alive no but we all know we all know we
all know we all know we all know the
truth okay he's still alive dude there
was like kids seeming in his bloodstream
but yeah he was mainlining that [ __ ]
that's just a [ __ ] lie dude
it's a [ __ ]
we don't [ __ ] talk about lies here
okay we don't perpetuate lies i think
michael jackson did it
i think he [ __ ] did it who did that
what did he do
all the all those kids
man i was thinking about this guy we
don't say that [ __ ] here
about like he's such a great musical
artist yeah he's a genius that people
are actually asking like ah but he still
made like he's got music you know i mean
like they beat it beat it still
you know beat it is still a good song
yeah yeah like he killed it you think it
it's better that he's a molester do you
think that makes him more of a genius a
musician or less than why would he make
him more of a genius yeah yeah
he's bringing up his weird points that's
crazy he's bringing up his weird points
i just want to know what he's talking
about no i think he's he just happened
to be a [ __ ] musical genius that
happened to you have a bad childhood
that made him you know one of the kids
will you get will you guys give a [ __ ]
if you like diet and then your legacy is
defamed and ruined no i don't give a
[ __ ] oh probably not dead
let's say you knew you did some [ __ ] but
you didn't get caught but then like you
knew you would get caught eventually you
know what i mean
like would that matter to you probably
not do you like need to go clean at the
end or you're just like [ __ ] it i'm not
i'm more of an honorable criminal and i
do good crimes that make people go man
that was cool joe was a cool guy
like you know like like big herc he did
a bank heist you know like that's a cool
crime you know like smuggling planes
that's a pretty cool you know
that's a really good crime you know like
they'll make a netflix movie out of me
like that kind of cool stuff like
[ __ ] kids but [ __ ] them well right
joe [ __ ] real well that's off limits
that's off limits that's off limits
while you're robbing a bank i was just
pitching
i got it no no no no no no no no no no i
don't want to know where your head's at
it's like rocking the world no
no no no no no no no no yeah
if you had to die by a vegetable which
one would it be
definitely
die by a vegetable yeah oh squash squash
squash you score you would choke on a
squash definitely not like getting hit
in the head with the watermelon like
that's my way that's how i want it you
won't want like choke on like a juicy
eggplant emoji type thing i mean that's
the way to go that's the way you're
gonna go sexual
damn
apparently that feels good people eating
a peach for days
i was watching this documentary and
these girls were um
they were um they were competing on who
can go deeper on the cucumber
wait what was the what was the list
documentary
[Laughter]
i know
i was watching this documentary about
shower dildos and it was really
interesting
you know this whole movement where like
step moms are teaching their sons about
sex nowadays yeah yeah watching
documentaries intersectionality that's
like very good
because the kid he's like he's like i
can't come
and then she's like well
that's interesting because i can help
with that
why what kind of what is that what do
you mean what is that like what
what
kind of docs are these that i'm that i'm
subscribing to tell me you're the ones
that you're the one that's got the
[ __ ] encyclopedia on pornography the
journals that joe's watching i'm asking
what is that joe will you direct the
porn please okay okay thank you that
should be the next otr i think he has
good porn i think he has good porn ideas
as well
but it's also my dna
yeah
if you directed a porn i think i have a
list in here in my notes of like uh
clever porn titles that i never made oh
tell me let me see if joe directed a
porn i would sit through the credits and
everything
the crusty krusty credits
you wrote this down uh here we go uh
triple x-men apocalypse
apocalypse
not a fan you don't like that apocalypse
not bad you get it's based off the
character apocalypse this one's good
uh shaft
they already have that
it's like it's already done for you
how about this to kill a cockering bird
oh come on cockroaches
[ __ ] and everything it's only cocker
ring started troopers started troopers
you're just saying like [ __ ] you're just
saying putting [ __ ] [ __ ] and [ __ ]
yeah all right enter the [ __ ] you're
just saying [ __ ] king dong school [ __ ]
island
yeah it's not bad okay jason born to
[ __ ] you in the ass that's crazy
the dummy matrix
that's not bad
dude bart's about to kill himself indica
jones
[Laughter]
how much time did anything i do
how many more do you have dude i'm done
dude
my ip is right here right
all you guys exploiting me for my genius
so [ __ ] you guys did you take adderall
and write that in four days
in four four minutes baby
[Music]
[Music]